[Applause]
20 years old
this is an embarrassment to america
what were you aiming at so where do you
want this there is no mole go
this is how you eat it don't do that tom
soda and a bounce bounce bounce stop
hanging yourself
nice hat want a bone cut it out tom
stop pooping
it's been kind of a crazy night what up
sky mall
[Music]
[Applause]
and i am running for city council cool
beans that
why i don't know can you trip wall
bam you're a steamroller
go throw up i didn't need any go throw
up too smart
when she likes them
oh god leslie
has anyone told you that yet that hurt
my feelings is that about right
yeah good look at that get
off the sportsmanship bro how do i look
there redness wags who wait i just want
to say thank you
well you you're very welcome i started a
business
for the gettysburg undressed we have a
problem what
therapy oh boy been hacked the worst
spread the sled gentlemen get my hoop
leslie
what one more question congratulations
i love you too daddy mommy please
who even are you so you've gone insane
that's what's up fart wads
i love sports i'm heard happily and i
just realized i'm not holding my
microphone
oh i love you too sushi and cigar club
now
are you grabbing my butt can you play me
no
what up five second rule
oh my god
sorry oh this whole company is ours
i will be at subway how dare you win
henry harrison's wig
we're sorry
[Music]
we're not against you on this treat
yourself
it's the best day of the year
you have a brother no
because of my life
this is awesome what was i thinking we
ran for again city councilor
another problem solved by the hard work
of dedicated public servants
okay great bye
yeah that's about right
you